obligatory disclaimer marvel studios is
an impenetrable fortress of secrecy and
few secrets make it out alive
still there's always the slim chance
that a nugget of truth will reach
daylight before the people in charge are
ready for it so here goes
well it remains to be seen whether it's
rumor conjecture or a real fact that
slipped through disney's fingers
there are rumblings that brooklyn
nine-nine actor stephanie beatrice will
be suiting up in the marvel cinematic
universe soon and a role you might not
expect
the website giant freaking robot is
reporting that the 39 year old actress
is being eyed to take over his ghost
rider marvel's sometimes spirit of
vengeance
guilty the site states that the scoop
comes from a source which has provided
reliable information in the past
filling in their team on kevin feige's
intention to block black widow from
moving straight to streaming
if true this would be far from the first
time that beatriz has been considered
for a high profile superhero role
and far from the first person rumored to
play ghost rider she was reportedly on
the short list to star in she-hulk
before tatiana maslanti landed the gig
and was also a candidate to replace ruby
rose following her departure from the
cw's batwoman
stephanie beatriz is best known for her
work playing rosa diaz on all seven
seasons of brooklyn nine-nine
her next project a movie adaptation of
the lin-manuel miranda musical in the
heights is scheduled for release in 2021
ghost rider in his familiar flames gold
form first appeared in marvel comics
back in 1972's marvel spotlight number
five
originally the most supernatural
superhero of all was the alter ego of
the cursed motorcycle stuntman johnny
blaze
an adrenaline junkie who made a pact
with mephisto summoning the comic book
devil through the most extreme and
nefarious means of all
poetry since then others have taken up
the mantle including blaze's brother dan
ketch and more recently
robbie reyes a potential mcu entry
wouldn't mark the first time that ghost
rider has taken a female form
in 2011 marvel's fear itself crossover
saw a central american woman briefly
take up the mantle of the spirit of
vengeance before having her powers
absorbed by johnny blaze
blaze's mother naomi kale also became
host to the spirit of vengeance
whether beatriz would play one of these
iterations a refreshed new character
remains unknown
as again does the likelihood that she'll
be taking over at all
ghost riders first live-action
appearance came in 2007 when nicholas
cage appeared on the big screen as the
johnny blaise incarnation of the
character
he followed up his performance a few
years later with the delightfully weird
and underrated sequel ghost rider spirit
of vengeance
held by crank directors mike neveldeen
and brian taylor
blaze made another brief cameo on
marvel's agents of shield the fourth
season of which also predominantly
featured the robbie reyes version of the
anti-hero
a hulu series based on the reyes ghost
rider was in development at marvel
television before the studio was folded
into marvel studios in late 2019
marvel's maneuvers toward a more
inclusive and diverse cinematic universe
have been notable in recent years
moving forward it's been confirmed that
natalie portman will take the reigns as
the new god of thunder wielding mjolnir
or some variant thereof and taika ytt's
upcoming thor love and thunder
other forthcoming projects include the
female lead black widow the studio's
first film starring an actor of asian
ancestry
chang chi in the legend of the ten rings
and a captain marvel sequel among others
while johnny blaze is almost definitely
the most well-known version of the
character this also wouldn't be the
first time that the mcu circumvented an
original iteration of one of their star
players in order to present a more
diverse story
free larson's carol danvers is one of
more than half a dozen characters to
take on the title of captain marvel
while samuel l jackson's nick fury
character spent the better part of his
first four decades as a white guy
while stephanie beatry's involvement in
the mcu moving forward is still far from
a sure thing
her inclusion as the motorcycle riding
soul burning anti-hero would certainly
take the character in new directions and
get people talking
be sure to check back often for the
latest on this and all marvel cinematic
universe rumors
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite marvel comics movies and
tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you